in the Pacific Ocean between Australia
and New Zealand is a barren ceasefire
that is home to the world's rarest
insect and what an insect it is this is
balls pyramid it is eighteen hundred and
forty-three feet tall it's 50% taller
than the Empire State Building and it
juts out of the Pacific Ocean it looks
like that like a supervillains lair and
in a funny way if you're really afraid
of huge insects it is a supervillains
lair meet dry oka Seles Australia's more
commonly known as the Lord Howe stick
insect but also referred to as the
walking sausage and the tree lobster it
used to live on Lord Howe Island which
is where it got its name it's a larger
island that's about 11 kilometers away
from balls pyramid so 1918 a ship the SS
Mocambo ran aground on Lord Howe Island
black rats escaped from the ship and
found waiting for them a delightful
treat in the form of the Lord Howe stick
insect they're pretty slow they're
really big and they probably taste
delicious
I mean if you're a rat it only took them
two years to drive the stick insect to
extinction by 1920 there was not another
report of a living Lord Howe Island
stick insect so it wasn't until 2001
that a couple of entomologist finally
made it out to ball's pyramid to
basically prove that the stick insect
was extinct and they got there and they
started looking around they came across
a single Bush they discovered living
after 80 years of being thought extinct
the last 24 Lord Howe Island stick
insects in the world the Lord Howe stick
insect was back from the dead and they
all lived under one tiny Bush on the
side of balls pyramid in the middle of
the Pacific Ocean once we discover these
insects uh they wanted to start a
breeding program they took four of these
stick insects two of them died in the
first week that left only two one male
and one female
which they of course named Adam and Eve
and after some
sing and near-death experiences of Eve
they were actually able to begin their
captive breeding program and they have
bred well over a thousand adults and
20,000 eggs at this point they are on
their way to quite a healthy population
of walking sausages which led some
people to say it's a real walking
sausage party in here
so after surviving for over 80 years in
isolation on balls pyramid the stick
insect is finally going to be
reintroduced to its Island home whether
the locals of the island will be pleased
to replace their rats with equally large
nocturnal dick insects remains to be
seen there's something to be said about
about being proud of your local species
however terrifying they may be click
here to subscribe or click here to watch
our other videos unusually for insects
they they form a bonded mating pairs one
one male and one female and when they
sleep the male cuddles the female like
big spoon style it's really nice I want
to hear what other nicknames you think
this wonderful creature should have I
think tree Lobster and walking sausage
are pretty good so let me know in the
comments what you think we should be
calling the Lord Hal stick insect